Should I take supplements on chemo day?
Should I stop coffee enemas after chemo at all?
So should I stop should I take my supplements on my day of chemo?
Well, usually your chemo and food fusion is going to be typically at the morning and it may last anywhere from a couple hours to half the day
I
Suggest you don't take your supplements in the morning before you go and do your infusion
But you can certainly take your afternoon supplements if you're feeling up to it. If you're feeling sick
that afternoon
And you don't feel like you can keep anything down that I would say don't worry about it. Don't stress about it
Just don't take your supplements and wait till you feel better
Typically, it's not the day of chemo that you feel sick though. Everybody experiences any illa that they may experience differently
so
It's a don't take your morning supplements, but take
The afternoon when you get home from your infusion if you can
Should I not do a coffee enemma?
Well, I would say don't do a coffee enemma at least the day of chemo
You could skip the coffee enemma the next day too
But then go back to doing your coffee enemas again
You could wait a maximum of two days
Between the coffee enemas now if you're only doing a couple of coffee enemas a week
Just wait a few days after the coffee enemma
Meeting after the chemo infusion meeting don't do a coffee enemma the day of chemo maybe don't do a coffee enemma the next day
On but then go back to doing your coffee enemas